la pandémie de covid 19 nous a rappelé
galère de la mondialisation les virus
voyage très rapidement c'est vrai des
virus qui affectent les humains mais
aussi de ceux qui s'attaquent aux
végétaux dans un environnement fermé
comme une serre un nouveau virus peut
rapidement faire beaucoup de dommages
[Musique]
c'est à Grenoble s'apprête à visiter une
serre de tomates
avant d'entrer il prend de grandes
précautions
il change ses habits chaque fois qu'il
inspecte une nouvelle serre un long
rituel pour éviter de propager un intrus
redoutable le virus du fruit rugueux
brun aussi surnommé rugos ou covid de la
tomate j'ai jamais vu un virus de cet
ampleur il entre dans une entreprise
puis peut décimer la production en trois
mois
hautement contagieux ce virus différent
de la covid chez l'humain fait trembler
les producteurs canadiens de tomates de
cerf
car il n'existe aucun traitement pour en
venir à bout je pense qu'on soit une
petite ou une grande entreprise l'idée
qu'un virus comme le virus la rue gauche
puisse entrer dans nos installations
puis compromettent une culture qui est
très importante chez nous là c'est la
tomate c'est vrai que c'est présent
parce que un coup que c'est là c'est
difficile de s'en débarrasser
[Musique]
Françoise Legault cultive plusieurs
variétés de tomates c'est le produit
signature de sa ferme biologique est-ce
que la décoloration le brunissement
d'une feuille comme ça pour être indiqué
que c'est on est en présence de rugos
puis je devrais m'inquiéter
l'aide à minimiser les risques de
contamination cette maladie-là apparaît
pas comme par miracle dans la salle il y
a pas de génération spontanée faux qu'à
la rive dans la serre
le virus du fruit rugueux brun détecté
pour la première fois en Israël en 2014
est maintenant présent sur tous les
continents
il est signalé pour la première fois au
pays en Ontario en 2019 il fait son
entrée au Québec deux ans plus tard
on ne connaît pas avec précision
l'ampleur de la contamination au Canada
nickel sert ont été où sont frappés par
le virus
des entreprises ont été infectées mais
elles souhaitent toutes gardées
l'anonymat actuellement on a une idée
très préliminaire de ce qui se passe au
niveau du Québec c'est à dire que c'est
comme c'est un virus qui se propage qui
est aussi très important et virulent il
y a très peu de producteurs qui osent
parler où on sait pas trop quel est le
portrait qu'on a
la plupart de ces entreprises privées ne
veulent pas de publicité négatives avec
ce virus
aussi elle craint de devenir la cible
des autorités réglementaires
alors ces entreprises évitent à tout
prix d'en parler moi
quand la rue gauche se faufile à
l'intérieur d'une serre voici ce qui se
passe
des boursouflures apparaissent sur les
feuilles
elle se décolore et présente une
mosaïque de verre les hanches florales
brûlées
les fruits eux avortent ou se pigmentent
de couleur il développe un aspect
rugueux avec des taches brunes
le virus est inoffensif pour l'humain
mais ses conséquences sur la production
peuvent être majeures
les producteurs peuvent vraiment subir
des pertes allant de 50% et plus
jusqu'au moment où il décide ok il y a
trop de pertes j'ai vu une serre quatre
mois après l'arrivée des plans 100% des
plantes infectés
[Musique]
quand les dégâts sont trop importants
les producteurs font un vide sanitaire
ils jettent la récolte vide la serre la
nettoie en profondeur et la désinfecte
avant de repartir la production et
surtout il se croisent les doigts car ça
ne garantit pas pour autant que le virus
soit éradiquer
avec ces immenses complexes à perte de
vue dans la région de liemington
l'Ontario est l’épicentre de la culture
de la tomate de cerf au pays la province
compte pour 70% de la production
canadienne devant la
Colombie-Britannique et le Québec une
grande partie de ces tomates est
destinée à l'exportation
[Musique]
en Ontario deux laboratoires
d'Agriculture et Agroalimentaire Canada
travaillent en étroite collaboration
avec l'industrie pour l'aider à passer à
travers la crise
on sait que le virus peut être transmis
par la semence donc ça certainement
c'est une porte d'entrée possible c'est
sûr que c'est la première chose à
regarder le point producteur qui
justement achète de la semence là il
faut poser ces questions là quelle
mesure sont prises quelle garantie à son
fournies est-ce qu'on veut demander que
des tests soient faits pour s'assurer
que les lots de semences soient exemple
soit certainement c'est la mesure numéro
à la ferme des ruisseaux Françoise
Legault sème à la graine tous les plans
qui entrent dans sa production elle est
vigilante quant à la provenance de ces
semences pour se protéger de la rue
gauche elle évite autant que possible
les semences qui ont été réencacées si
c'est pas un sachet d'un sachet original
je peux je peux faire un désinfection de
nos semences on utilise un traitement à
l'eau chaude il existe aussi des
traitements qui peuvent se faire avec de
l'eau de javel à une certaine dilution
au Québec des chercheurs tentent
d’évaluer l'ampleur de la contamination
et d'aider les producteurs en serres
québécois donc proposer différentes
alternatives une des alternatives avec
ce virus là c'est de désinfecter les
semences l'équipe de Philippe constante
termine les essais de trempage et de
désinfections des semences avec entre
autres l'eau de javel et l'acide
chlorhydrique
[Musique]
ment
mais vraiment la petite chlorhydrique et
la norme actuellement c'est ce qui est
plus simple à utiliser et donc on a
commencé par ce traitement là pour
s'assurer qu'on avait une solution
rapide à mettre en place sur le terrain
les plats sont vraiment super beaux
virus non détectés également ici tu peux
voir les contrôles détection de Jeanne
marqueurs chez la plante quand on fait
même expérience pour le virus on détecte
plus rien donc c'est 100% d'efficacité
le virus du fruit rugue brun de la
tomate peut aussi survivre dans les
substrats de plantations comme le
terreau et la fibre de coco Philippe
constant valide en laboratoire une
méthode de décontamination prometteuse
on peut rajouter aussi quelques composés
pour activer davantage de la chaleur on
pense au chlorure de potassium notamment
qui est ajouté dans le substrat pour
atteindre température plus élevée plus
rapidement
le virus peut aussi se transmettre par
simple contact avec des fruits des plans
des racines ou encore avec la
manipulation d'outils ça peut être les
mains des travailleurs ça peut être les
outils qu'on utilise la machinerie qu'on
fait circuler dans la culture pour
travailler avec donc vraiment juste un
contact mécanique tout va être mais un
contact direct n'a pas nécessairement
transmis par l'air comme le coronavirus
il y a une autre voie de transmission
possible
les insectes pollinisateurs pourtant
essentiels dans la culture des tomates
en serre pour assurer de bons rendements
si le virus est présent que un plan est
infecté les bourdons risque fort de
propager le virus dans la serre
[Musique]
et le virus est sournois il peut
survivre pendant des années à différents
endroits comme des poignées de porte ou
de l'équipement informatique
[Musique]
pour éviter le pire il faut détecter sa
présence le plus tôt possible
laissez agriculteurs ont accès à une
première méthode de dépistage un test
rapide semblable à celui utilisé pour
détecter la covid-19 chez lui-même
dans son laboratoire Geneviève marchand
nous montre comment ce test fonctionne
la chercheuse écrase une feuille de
plante tomate inoculée avec le virus
elle insère ensuite une bandelette dans
le sachet quand deux lignes rouges
apparaissent l'échantillon est positif
c'est sûr que ce genre de Tesla ça a été
développé plus dans le contexte médical
mais lentement ça fait son chemin vers
le monde de l'agriculture
Françoise Legault une ancienne
infirmière est à l'affût des méthodes de
détection de la covid de la tomate
aujourd'hui elle va faire l'essai d'un
nouveau test de dépistage développé par
un laboratoire privé à la demande du
ministère ontarien de l'agriculture ce
qu'on fait on est un peu comme de la
police scientifique qui vient sur une
scène de crime on récupère des
échantillons ici et là on analyse on
décolle l'ADN on va regarder le code ADN
sur une base de données et on cherche
notre petit criminel qui dans ce cas là
et le virus de la rugos de la tomate
dans la serre la productrice frotte des
écouvillons secs sur des surfaces
souvent manipulées par les employés
système d'arrosage écran tactile
manivelle poignée de porte c'est vrai
que ça m'a étonné que ce soit pas le
matériel végétal qu'on analyse parce que
souvent quand on soupçonne un problème
une maladie mais c'est la plante au
complet ou les fruits ou des feuilles
qu'on va envoyer au laboratoire de Phyto
pour avoir un statistiques du problème
mais c'est vrai que ça se retrouve dans
l'environnement donc je les échantillons
tout le matériel de laboratoire tient
sur une petite table Rémy mallionnay
prépare les échantillons puis il lance
le protocole pour récupérer le matériel
généreux avec un séquenceur de la
grosseur d'un téléphone relié à un
ordinateur portable c'est aussi quelque
chose que on aimerait proposer dans un
futur j'irai un moyen terme de
développer justement une boîte noire où
le producteur n'aurait plus qu'à mettre
son échantillon et aurait un résultat et
on veut vraiment pouvoir apporter en
fait les technologies de séquençage
directement à la ferme les tests de
détection rapide au point de au point de
production oui c'est certainement
quelque chose qui peut être utilisé dans
l'avenir un peu partout dans le monde
des scientifiques planchent sur un
projet à long terme
il tente d'identifier les gènes de
résistance les chercheurs utilisent des
variétés de tomates ancestrales plus ou
moins sauvages qui proviennent de
banques de semences il en existe des
centaines de milliers de variétés
[Musique]
le virus circule dans la nature elles
sont respectées
elles ont évolué et elles ont développé
des mécanismes de résistance
c'est pourquoi elles sont si importantes
en termes de diversité génétique
pour réussir à identifier le gène de
résistance il faut d'abord infecter ses
plans avec le virus sur mes tables j'ai
deux plantes qui ne sont pas infectées
et j'ai des plantes qui sont infectées
avec deux préparations différentes du
virus donc c'est ça qu'on fait
essentiellement mais ce qu'on évalue
c'est pas sur la base d'une plante
individuelle c'est sur la base de cette
espèce ou cette collection de semences
là comment elle répond à la présence du
virus essentiellement est-ce qu'elle
montre des symptômes
le gène de résistance devra ensuite être
introduit dans les variétés cultivées en
serre par croisement ou encore grâce aux
techniques de génie génétique
et avec l'augmentation de la fréquence
d'irrigation ton plan va sur place en
peinture quand il fera pas beau ça va
être excellent le pour le développement
d'ici est-ce que des variétés
résistantes soient disponibles Sébastien
couture conseille aux producteurs de
développer des plans forts et vigoureux
qui pourront survivre plus longtemps aux
assauts du virus
autrement dit apprendre à vivre avec la
covid de la tomate mais on peut ralentir
beaucoup la progression et rendre la
production viable financièrement c'est
au final
[Musique]